[Música]
boa tarde gente então eu soubesse
adorado e desde criança já era bem
expressiva a mãe conta que há 16 anos eu
tenho os meus questionamentos sobre a
vida e se tratava mais ou menos assim
mãe o que é isso mãe que vem crescendo
aqui dentro de mim
como pode a botar um grande campeão aqui
ainda sobre gramática bem eu acredito
que a arte auxilia as pessoas ampliar
essas percepções além de desenvolverem
um olhar mais sensível para o outro e
com um olhar mais sensível
seremos capazes de perceber o que o
outro está sentindo
valorizando assim a empatia a arte é
expressão é passar uma mensagem a poesia
também é a arte não é escrita em si mas
sim a inspiração o sentimento é estar
presente no presente sentir e deixar sem
sentido é a beleza da conexão
logo podemos disseminada pelo sorriso
pelo olhar pela forma de falar então eu
te pergunto o que tem transmitido com as
conexões têm feito
sejamos poesia todos os dias em todo
instante a todos
agora eu gostaria que vocês virassem
para a pessoa que está ao seu lado e
olhar em seus olhos e por 10 segundos
vocês irão se conectar e conversar
apenas pelo olhar podem se você olha a
gente
interessante não é bom quantas vezes nós
passamos pelas pessoas e nem olhar nem
olhamos nos seus olhos ou mais
estamos conversando com alguém olhando
mas não enxergando não estamos nem 90
por cento focados no momento o olhar
ele fala e sim um sorriso pode mudar um
dia sejamos poesia
indecisos
distraídos atraída
andam perdidos e achados em meio a
tantos inscritos arraigados pelos
extintos pobres de espírito mais
famintos momentos de vida
[Música]
correndo atrás dos liberais porém
esquecendo os essenciais os reais tornar
os seus escravos da monotonia e
parceiros da desarmonia existindo como
autômatos afastando da sensibilidade à
sociedade
desarmou amor deixou de navegações
importou apenas com a exibição
esses motivos é questão mas algo que
eles chegaram a próprio senhor falta de
iluminações por falsa
idealizamos quando indicadores salvos
liberdade fotos falsas faltas
[Música]
o fato não faça faça não faça
meu nome
não desista de lutar pelas idéias que
moldaram o futuro pelas atitudes que
formaram os aprendizes de amanhã
não se prenda um fato que o uso se torna
mais obscura a cada dia
ei não desista pois em contrapartida nós
estrelas juntas
brigaremos mais e claro aremu esse mundo
lamy ficado portanto razão se borra
[Música]
muito
sonhando acreditando e realiza
ajudando que os outros realizem também
estabelecer conexões
a peça deus corações olhar dentro do
interior e viver o amor
[Música]
sem tim sorrir transmitir façamos um
mundo à parte o melhor que o mundo de
pessoas que vão atrás do bem ao próximo
onde compartilhar vida se faz
fundamental e viver da melhor forma se
torna essencial empatia em companhia em
amor sem monotonia sem segregação no
qual andaram todos em sintonia em
harmonia
então o de dentro de si
era um homem simpático que aí deixe ver
o filho da cidade sorriso deixa a
sensibilidade se expressar
deixem me dizer não e beija seu celular
além disso precisa falar com sua conexão
seja mtur
a inspiração a bela canção
a alegria
que fui no dia a dia
sejamos poesia obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]